in this video we'll talk about
inflammatory bowel disease
which is an umbrella term used to
describe disorders in the intestine
which involves chronic inflammation
now ibd could be really debilitating and
sometimes it could also increase
the
complications and it could be fatal as
well
let's talk about the symptoms
the major symptoms of ibd includes
persistent diarrhea rectal bleeding
sometimes weight loss abdominal pain and
extreme fatigue
let's talk about the subtypes
there are two subtypes of
inflammatory bowel disease one is known
as crohn's disease and another
one is known as ulcerative colitis
the major differences between these two
is in cone crohn's disease
the
the affected part could be any part of
the gi tract
whereas in the ulcerative colitis
the inflammation occurs selectively in
the large intestine that means the colon
now there are even subdivisions of
ulcerative colitis and crohn's disease
in this video we are not going to go
into that much details let's keep these
things simple
in crohn's disease the inflamed areas
appear in patches and that kind of
that kind of forms a salt and pepper
formation with the healthy tissue
in ulcerative colitis the inflamma
inflam tissue is kind of like in
continuum so one continuous portion of
inflam tissue is found in ulcerative
colitis
let's talk about the risk factors of
developing ibd
major risk factors involved
smoking and stress additional risk
factors involve age mostly ibd develops
within 30 years of age but sometimes in
rare occasions
50 people in 50s or 60s have also
developed ibd
races and ethnicity is an important
factor
research suggests that majorly
the white race is basically
more susceptible for
ibd but it can occur in any race
now if there is a family history of
ibd you are more likely to get an ibd
that means there is a strong genetic
component associated with ibd just like
any other disease inflammatory bowel
disease also has some genetic and
sporadic component that means some
environmental factors and gene related
risk factors
let's talk about the immunology and
pathophysiology of inflammatory bowel
disease so in inflammatory bowel disease
the colonic lesions
show excessive immune infiltration
and that leads to tissue destruction
so the major expression of stat 3 and
interleukin 17 are quite hallmark of
inflammatory bowel disease
th17 cells
are one subgroup of t cells which
secretes interleukin-17
and that is thought to be the most
important factor or player in
inflammation in the inflammatory bowel
disease
other than that
antigen presenting cells also take part
in this process and several chemokines
such as ccl2 ccl3 to ccl 20 take part in
the overall pathophysiology of
inflammatory bowel disease
now t helper cell can be subdivided into
many groups such as th1 cells which are
also inflammatory in nature th2 cells
th17 cells
th
t follicular cells just to name name few
of them
among them th17 cell is the key focus in
the inflammatory bowel disease though
active research is going on but the
major association of th17 cells in
bowel disease is really important
anyway in general th17 cells are
associated with many autoimmune
disorders th17 cells secretes
interleukin-17 and interleukin-22 both
of them leads to inflammation in several
tissues or organs
by the way recently researchers found
out that gut microbiome
of a gut microbiome is altered
in the patients with ibd and this is a
very important uh
discovery
because gut microbiome can denote many
things
now people really don't know whether gut
microbiome is the causal of ibd or it is
associated with ibd
anyway the current uh research scenario
uh kind of points out that there is a
compensatory balance of immune systems
in the
intestine
whenever there is a balance between
anti-inflammatory cytokine and
pro-inflammatory cytokine goes
everywhere it could increase the risk of
ibd and in ibd it has been shown that
pro-inflammatory cytokines are
predominant and the anti-inflammatory
cytokines and the cells that secrete
anti-inflammatory cytokines are reduced
that means this balance is altered and
due to the perturbation of this
homeostasis
there is overall massive inflammation in
the intestine along with that people
have noticed the change with a change in
the gut microbiome composition many gut
microbiome may additionally put some
give some contribution on this
inflammation
let's talk about the diagnosis option
when to see a doctor is the important
question if you have a persistent pain
in bubble movement if you have problems
in uh
whenever you are
doing a
in in terms of your stool if you have
problems then you might see a doctor
although inflammatory bowel disease
usually is not fatal
but it should not be ignored sometimes
it can create many complications and if
it is diagnosed properly the treatment
options are better
so it is diagnosed by endoscopy or
colonoscopy let's talk about the
treatment option treatment option
involves several medications including
anti-inflammatory drug antibiotics and
immune system suppressors
the extreme conditions
involve surgery but with a combination
of medications and dietary modifications
things could get better i hope this
video was useful
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up
the notes associated with this video can
be found in my facebook page links are
in the description there are lot of
interactive flash cards and dynamic
flash cards which would help in your
preparation
as usual like share and subscribe please
put your comment in a comment and tell
me how you like these videos or not
anyway my my
channel needs support and you can
support me via patreon my channel is
also present in academy which is india's
biggest online learning platform using a